(people murmuring)
- It's so confusing
that hipsters
have started co-opting
southern culture.
I feel like we're in a
Cracker Barrel cosplay party.
- Drew, don't say
co-opt too loud.
They're gonna think we wanna
start a beet farm coalition.
I really need some
fried okra, man,
so can we please
just make this work?
- Corey, everyone
in here's dressed
like a barista at Talladega.
- Are you ready to order?
- Yes, ma'am, I'll--
- We don't use gendered
pronouns in this restaurant.
- Okay, well I heard that y'all
have the best fried chicken,
so I'll take a two piece, dark,
with some mashed
potatoes and gravy.
- Okay, we don't have gravy
and we only serve white meat.
- That's why it's all
white people in here.
- Excuse me?
- 'Cause of the blandness--
- White is fine, and I'll just
take the cheese grits instead.
- Okay, would you
like regular or vegan?
- Regular?
What?
Vegan grits?
That's just dry ass corn.
Who would wanna eat that?
- People dressed
like an Americana
album about soybean subsidies.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
Track one, white meat got
me dryer than white men.
Am I right?
- Hilarious.
Is that one SoundCloud?
- This is ridiculous.
You guys have vegan
options all over the menu.
There's a deer head on the wall.
- His name is William.
We're honoring him.
- I like your trucker hat.
What do you haul?
- Apparently
cognitive dissonance.
- This is just an outfit.
- (laughs) Look, Drew!
Your dad's an outfit.
- And you can wear it to your
next hillbilly hoedown party!
I hope y'all are diggin'
the reclaimed barn wood,
'cause there's poop in barns!
We're eating in a poop lodge.
- That's not true.
There's no poo in here.
- That lady has a mullet.
- Whoa, whoa, hey, hold on!
What the hell's
going on out here?
I'm up in my ass in
grease that's hotter
than a randy bobcat's
butt hole back there.
What's the deal?
- These customers are upset.
They think that light
meat chicken is dry.
- Is that right?
- Mm-hmm.
- I'll take care of this.
We got a chicken problem?
- And, uh, the Earnhardt
poster's crooked.
- Well, by god!
Livin', breathin' Yelp
review comin' in here,
pitchin' a fit before he's
even had a bite to eat yet.
I swear to Conway Twitty
you make me want (sighs).
When you're hotter than
grease, say yes to peace.
When you're hotter than grease--
- Buddy, where are you from?
- Boone, North Cackalacky.
- Boone, North Carolina?
You mean your parents
had a vacation
house outside of
Asheville, right?
- No, I mean like
my uncle's still
on the run from breeding
illegal reptiles.
- You're from Boone, North
Carolina and you made this menu?
- Yes.
- What year did Doc Watson die?
- What?
- What percentage
Cherokee are you?
- 1/16th on my mama's side.
1/8th on my daddy's side.
- Vinegar or
ketchup-based barbecue?
- Both.
- When greeting a
fellow southerner--
- Scoot, scoot, goddamn!
- How much sugar
goes in sweet tea?
- Til it's sweet enough.
- Dolly Parton or--
- Dolly!
You know, unless the
preacher's comin' over.
Then we gotta pretend like
it's Jesus for a minute, but.
- All right.
When you were punished as a kid,
where would you parents hit you?
- Home, school, church.
Anywhere with sticks, really.
- That's a phenomenal answer.
- Mm-hmm.
Just a few more questions.
- Willie gets all the credit
because he started it,
but Waylon's the best outlaw.
Skynyrd's plane went down
in Gillsburg, Mississippi.
You can fry anything if
the grease is hot enough.
And Doc Watson died
on May 29th, 2012.
Smart ass.
- Dude, why are you
making vegan grits?
- 'Cause they sell.
And they ain't that bad!
And doctor told me I
got the prediabetes, so.
- [Both] Oh!
- Hell, man.
Why didn't you say something?
- I'll have the catfish.
Tell your mama and
them I said hey.
- Okay then.
That's a sweet mullet.
Somebody fix Dale.
- I like this place.